[Music]
well John is a fan of the room what you
think I mean this made me excited I
didn't know really what to expect from
this it seems like James Franco's really
going all out on that impersonation it
sounds pretty good you know I like that
they led with just a seat that's kind of
the best thing I feel like they could
have done with this well I feel like
with James Franco and Seth Rogen style a
comedy and a Franco being in there not
to their kind of scenes work better not
in trailer format when you're cutting
two jokes but in terms of how a scene
plays out and how banter plays out yeah
how things escalate to it's very much in
the reactions and in the sort of
interplay of everybody and there are a
lot of other people in this to the
culture and Charlene yeah Emily they've
got a lot of people for this and James
Franco looks like Tommy wise oh yeah
like I didn't know if I would buy it
that much but at least something few
seconds like yeah I bought it it looks a
lot like a me sounds a lot like yeah and
I was directing this too and this might
be cheap spray goes first big like
there's a lot of people are really
excited for this movie in it I feel like
this might actually be James Franco's
first big directional he directed a few
films that this might be his first big
one
this actually performs well at the box
office because there's a lot of
anticipation for them yeah I mean this
film has a legendary status now like its
screen kind of since it came out so yeah
I think it could definitely be that for
James Franco there's certainly eyeballs
on and Colin at the disaster artist and
seen the behind have Ian for people who
follow the room they know a lot about
the bad behind the scenes that went down
and you could just see the film and see
how it's a product of all that I'm
excited to see what is the comedic
approach to this you know the room is an
unintentional laughs s but the here is
like knows an intentional laughter I
feel like I can watch Ed Wood and in
this yeah I hope that those become a
nice double feature what by the time
this is done and everything is out I've
gathered from over the years just
reading think pieces and stuff these
dudes or at least you know their crew
Adam Jonah Hill and Paul Rudd some of
the people are kind of verified as
having attended these screenings by
being in love with this film for years
before this even came together so I
wonder who else is going to show up on
the film they have stone you know I love
that James Franco and Seth Rogen
become such good buddies yeah you know
they're like us thank you hi there
little boards my head like oh and Dave
Franco - I mean ya ever heard of that
Funny or Die sketch for - Riggins a
q-tip yeah yeah yeah dave Franco does
look so dejected throughout all of them
because I feel like they both have
created their own career paths I don't
feel like when you see Dave Franco you
don't go James Franco his brother I feel
like he has established himself as his
own right now yeah so it's cool to see
them like in a film together under James
Franco's direction that is well it's
funny to see them play those two
characters too because you know Greg
Sestero and Tommy Wiseau are two of the
key figures especially as it pertains to
the book you know because Greg Sestero
at least co-wrote that book to see
Brothers play these two guys who are at
least very close even best friends is
interesting because yeah they look like
different guys on screen yeah from each
other I can tell who they are but I'm
not sitting here being like that
brothers this is weird yeah there's huge
cast assembled for this film you got
algebra in here so we've got Lizzy
Caplan Zac Efron
Bryan Cranston Kristen Bell like there's
so many peseta Rogen of course dave
Franco Adam Scott Judd Apatow Sharon
Stone this is a huge catalyst and you
only got a peek at just a few of these
players into film dealing Monessen this
too so I'm pretty excited to see this
movie I want to watch the room like a
week before this movie comes out oh yeah
yeah yeah we'll watch it every week up
until he goes it is a ghost it's a cult
hit that film you know yeah I move it
was like a cult phenomenon it seemed
like it just grew on its own I paid for
a billboard and and it's screened I
think at least until the the Sun set
five changed it screened every weekend
for years and years and year like over
ten years ago yeah this movie is
something else and James trying to grow
such a hit or miss for me totally yeah
yeah the movie yeah it's like if he
doesn't really care about it it shows if
he cares about it it shows yeah yeah it
seems like he's put down it seems like
he cares about it because I feel like he
could have been a lot more over the top
just in this one scene like if you watch
like him in the interview for example
he's super over-the-top yeah not in the
reality whatsoever rivaling Tom Cruise
levels of smiling yeah that is awful in
that film but here he seems like he's
really taking his he had the comedic
chops down but he also seems like he's
taking it with a sense of realism yeah
because especially just through these
beats it seems like he actually brought
some actual performance to that instead
of just doing an impression you know
yeah like he allowed the moments to
still sink and it was kind of hard when
at least one of those takes is based on
what's in that movie you know like you
have a specific cadence that was what I
was worried about with this partially
was you know James Franco is going to
lead that this movie and if you're gonna
play Tommy woods oh he is so specific
that you have to do a good job yeah if
you can't just be the Tommy Wiseau that
you saw in the room you have to be who
he is off camera yeah yeah which is a
movie might be a little more challenging
actually yeah like from the little
things I've seen in family seeing the
man in person and seeing how he behaves
when he's not in scenes I feel like he
probably studied the one cuz I would
imagine him dis actually since he's
directing it to ya actually put it all
into it
this is living the like that what Tommy
was doing arguably at the time yeah well
guys thanks for tuning and you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification battle shout out again at
the egg of shy Dez and also - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
last but not least patreon.com slash the
real early jex now remember love is
blind
[Music]